volcanoes the ultimate natural force of
destruction they're unforgiving
uncompromising and unstoppable about
1,500 volcanoes around the world are
considered to be active with more than
10% of them in the United States is
there any way we could stop them before
the destruction begins could we
literally fight fire with fire what if
we nuked an active volcano would it
solve the problem or make it way worse
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we nuked an active volcano
volcanoes are as cool as they are
terrifying they are an incredible force
of nature capable of destroying our
lives on their path of destruction but
could we give them a taste of their own
medicine how could we nuke such a fiery
Inferno well we'd need to bring out the
big guns the nuclear bomb dropped on
Hiroshima Japan during World War two was
the equivalent of over 130 million
kilograms of TNT that had plenty of
impact could we use something like it to
blow a volcano to smithereens first we'd
have to figure out the target Wow
it's difficult to predict when a volcano
will erupt there are some warning signs
watch for things like tiny earthquakes
releases of steam and other gases from
the volcano's mouth and bulging from the
sides
sounds like my last date
that being said whether the volcano will
erupt is still a massive educated guess
so
let's say that our scientists locked on
to an active volcano that's ready to
blow it would be a miracle if they could
coordinate with the military fast enough
to try and stop it ideally we'd be able
to predict it a few days before the
volcano was about to explode this would
provide more than enough time for people
to pack up their belongings and evacuate
without causing the kinds of highway
traffic jams we see during hurricanes
tsunamis and other disasters with
everyone out of harm's way
geologists volcano ologists and weapons
experts would determine any weak spots
on a volcano sides that could be hit
effectively next a highly-trained crew
of pilots would fly over the volcano
drop their payload and get the heck out
of Dodge if things worked perfectly as
in if they used the exact right amount
of explosives and hit the perfect spot
in exactly the right way the top of the
volcano would crumble into itself
keeping the magma mostly underground
there might still be some seepage around
the base of the volcano but it wouldn't
be anything like how the eruption would
have played out naturally but if we're
being honest it would be like trying to
put out fire with gasoline geologists
warned that trying to bomb a volcano
might actually make things worse a lot
worse the explosion of the bomb mixed
with the build-up of pressure inside a
volcano could amplify the eruption the
force would release even more ash and
lava spreading it even further than it
would have gone with the volcano's own
power and that's if we managed to hit
the target if the nuke missed its target
there's still a nuclear bomb being
dropped in an area where people live or
at least near enough that they would
feel the effects of the radiation if you
had to pick one which would you choose
death by lava horn
nuclear destruction we can't bomb our
way out of this problem the same way we
can't stop magma from building up under
volcanoes here at what F we've tried
throwing trash and pouring liquid
nitrogen into volcanoes long story short
it doesn't work don't mess with
volcanoes as cool as it sounds on paper
nuking a volcano just won't work while
man-made firepower can be impressive
nature isn't quaking in its boots at
what we can do but since our trigger
fingers are itchy what if we tried
combating another natural disaster with
a nuke what if we nuked a hurricane well
that's a story for another what if
you